في تلك الأثناء ، يحذر المئات من
كبار الأطباء في العالم إليزابيث الآن
239 منهم من توقيع هذه الرسالة
قائلين إنهم يريدون المزيد من
الاعتراف العام بأن فيروس كورونا
يمكن أن يطفو وينتقل عبر قطرات الهواء ،
لكن يجب أن أقول عندما قرأت
هذا ، فكرت في نفسي  ألا
نعلم بالفعل أن هذا ليس
سبب أهمية الأقنعة ، فهذا أمر
محير للغاية وهو نوع من التمييز
الذي يفهمه العلماء ولكن في بعض الأحيان
يكون من الصعب الحصول عليه حقًا ، لذلك دعونا نتحدث
عن هذا في الغالب عما
تحدثت عنه السلطات عنك  يمكن رؤيته على صفحة الويب الخاصة بـ CDC
هو أنه ينتشر من خلال
العطس والسعال بمعنى آخر
يجب أن يكون هناك شيء ما يدفعه ،
ولكن كان هناك الكثير من الحديث عن أنه
حتى مجرد التنفس يمكن أن ينشره ،
فأنت لا تحتاج حقًا إلى هذا النوع من
تدفع للحصول عليها للحصول على ذلك فقط
لنشر الفيروس وهذا ليس سرا كبيرا ،
فقد أخبرت الأكاديمية الوطنية للعلوم
البيت الأبيض هذا منذ أكثر من
ثلاثة أشهر.  يعتقدون أن مجرد
التنفس يمكن أن ينشر هذا الفيروس ،
والآن يخبر هؤلاء العلماء أكثر من 200
منهم منظمة الصحة
العالمية ، فلنتحدث عن هذا
علانية ، فالكلمة المحمولة جواً مخيفة ، لكن
دعنا نتحدث عن هذا بصراحة أن
هذا ينتشر بسهولة أكبر على ما يبدو
ما أظهرته الدراسات أكثر مما اعتقده الناس في
البداية ،
لذا قلت للتو إنهم أصغر من
35 إلى 45 عامًا وكيف يمكن أن يكون ذلك
مخيفًا وأنت تعلم بوضوح أن حاكم
ولايتك DeSantis قال إن متوسط
مر في شهر مارس للحالات كان  65
والآن هي 36 ، وهذا نوع من ما
تقوله - والحقيقة هي أن
الطبيب أنت وأنا نعلم أن الكثير من
الشباب يعتقدون أنه لن
يمرضوا حقًا وهكذا  لن
يؤثر عليهم حقًا أنه
لن يكون مجرد مشكلة بالنسبة لهم ، ما
الذي تقوله للأشخاص الذين لديهم هذا الشعور
بالنظر إلى ما تراه في المستشفى ،
فأنت تعلم أن هذه نقطة رائعة ما
ذكرته لذلك
يعتقد الشباب أحيانًا أن  لن تمرض ey ،
ويعتقدون أن معظم الأمراض الأخرى مخصصة
لجميع المرضى ، لكن هذه نسخة 19 ،
يمكن لأي شخص أن يمرض من الأصغر
إلى الأكبر سنًا وأعتقد أن هذا ما
نراه الآن ، كما أشرت إلى أننا رأينا
الجميع من  يموت 34 إلى 45 في وحدة العناية المركزة ،
لذا فإن الرسالة الموجهة للشباب هي أنهم
يمكن أن يمرضوا أيضًا ويجب عليهم أيضًا
الاعتناء بأنفسهم ،
فأنا لست قلقًا بشأن التغطية بعد الآن ،
أعتقد أنني قلق أكثر بشأن
إطلاق النار ، نعم لست قلقًا لأن كل منهم
تعرف أطقم اليوم أن 19
مريضًا يتم تغطيتهم في
مستشفى الطوارئ الميداني هذا لديهم فرصة جيدة جدًا
للخروج بعد بضعة أيام فقط من
تباطؤ معدل الوفيات لدينا ، وهذا ليس حقًا
ما قمنا بنمذجه من شأنه أن يثلج ما لدينا
توقعنا أن الوفيات
ستستمر
وستتسلق في الواقع بشكل كبير جدًا وستين كيب
رئيس طب الطوارئ يقول لي والاس
إن النماذج المبكرة تنبأت
بالكارثة هنا بطريقة
تجعلك محظوظًا لأنك كنت في وقت لاحق في هذا الوباء  ج
بالتأكيد نعلم أننا تعلمنا قدرًا كبيرًا
من الصين من أوروبا في
الولايات المتحدة.  ما تعلموه هو استخدام أجهزة التنفس الصناعي
كملاذ أخير
ولا يعمل الجسم بشكل جيد في مثل هذه
الظروف يتسبب هذا الفيروس في الكثير من
الضرر لكل من الرئتين والأوعية
الدموية في الرئتين وتحتاج حقًا
إلى نظام الجسم نفسه  محاربته
قدر الإمكان ، بدأوا مبكرًا
باستخدام الأكسجين الأنفي عالي التدفق بدلاً من استخدام
غالون وجالونات في الدقيقة
لكل مريض ، مما يجعلهم نشيطين
ويقظون المرضى قالوا
إننا قبل أسبوع قمنا بتهوية هذا
المريض وكان لديهم نتائج سيئة.
نحن الآن
نستخدم الأكسجين الأنفي ويخرجون إلى المستشفى ،
كل مريض يتناول الأكسجين هنا يحصل على
مضادات التخثر لتقليل مخاطر
تجلط الدم والمنشطات التي تؤكدها
نتائج دراسة حديثة في أكسفورد تظهر
أنها يمكن أن تنقذ الأرواح
في أكثر المرضى مرضًا  ينتقل الفيروس
الآن أسرع من أي وقت مضى هنا مع
أيام من الزيادات القياسية في
الحالات المؤكدة ، ويتحرك مركز الزلزال بسرعة إلى
جوهانسبرج
يقول الأطباء إن التوقعات خطيرة
اللعبة التي نواجهها بفشل كبير
في هذا السيناريو السري بالكامل ، وأعتقد
أننا استخدمنا الوقت جيدًا وأننا
كنا نسأل
أنفسنا دائمًا هل استخدمناها بما يكفي ، فعلنا ما
يكفي مع الوقت الذي كنا فيه  تم إعطاؤهم
أثناء الإغلاق عندما تتباطأ الأوبئة ،
لكنهم يأملون أن تستمر الدروس التي
تعلموها في علاج المرضى في كيب
تاون في إنقاذ الأرواح في جميع أنحاء
البلاد مع انتشار الوباء بما
هو عليه جحيم السرير الفارغ ، أعتقد جيدًا أن هذا
مستشفى للأمل لذلك هم  أعتقد أنهم
يجب أن يمنحونا الأمل في أنه يمكننا التعامل
مع الوباء واليوم هذه أخبار جيدة
50 أفضل الأخبار الجيدة تمامًا ديفيد
ماكنزي سي إن إن كيب تاون